new species can now be added to the list
of creatures that can use tools the
Hawaiian crow better known by its
indigenous Hawaiian name alala we've
known for a long time that a Lala are
extremely intelligent but it wasn't
until we conducted this study that we
realized just how skilled a Lala are at
using tools for example nearly all adult
a Lala used tools and they can all
extract a food item from a small crevice
in less than one minute members of the
crow family or corvids are known to be
smart but before this discovery
there was only one species known to be a
naturally expert tool user the New
Caledonian crow I have been studying New
Caledonian crows for over 10 years now
and in the course of that research I
started wondering whether the New
Caledonian crow really is the only crow
species that naturally uses tools to
find out researchers tempted captive
alala with little pieces of meat buried
in holes and crevices inside a piece of
wood we were surprised just how good a
Lala are at using tools and they were
incredibly fast even by comparison to
New Caledonian crows we also observed a
Lala selecting different kinds of tools
exchanging tools when they were not
happy with the tool their first selected
modifying tools we observed Birds
shortening tools that were too long and
finally we were able to show in a
separate experiment that juvenile a Lala
will independently develop tor using
skills even if they had never
opportunities to observe tool proficient
adult or even tool using humans
there are only around 100 alala left in
the world and they're all currently in
captivity but later this year some of
these birds will be released allowing
scientists to look for tool use behavior
in the wild this might be tricky but it
will prove that the Olalla deserves its
place amongst the top tool users of the
animal kingdom
[Music]
[Music]